this summer  teammates are put to the test  to decide if they'll commit  or move on  i'm so happy for you  you're not gonna be mad about it i'm not  mad  why would i be mad  with kyrie and kd let things play out  and see what happens lebron and russ i  made a decision that's why it's called  play around and feeding harden  uncle baron mitchell there's a lot of  people that would love for us to break  apart deandre hayden and his sons so you  can play most of the fourth quarter  there's any reason why is that hurt or  it's interesting good times and bad  [Music]  will this summer tear them apart  everybody expected  uh the  houston james harden that's not who he  is anymore or unite them forever  or at least until the all-star break  everyone's looking for a ring  so it might be the time to flirt  the ultimatum free agency or you sit at  home and  you know now we get to talk [ __ ] about  your decision and  and you personally